[Musica]
due conflitti mondiali nove anni di
guerra ma un'eredità pesantissima le
bombe inesplose
ma quante sono queste bombe inesplose
secondo una statistica del dipartimento
difesa americano
le bombe lanciate solo nel secondo
conflitto mondiale
sono un milione l'equivalente di 380.000
tonnellate di questo quantitativo il 10
per cento non ha funzionato quindi
stiamo parlando di 38 38 mila tonnellate
ad oggi sono stati recuperati il 60 per
cento quindi ne rimangono ancora da
recuperare
16 mila tonnellate mi piace e mi
piacerebbe dirvi così ma non è così
purtroppo
a queste bisogna aggiungere tutte le
bombe utilizzate dal dai tedeschi tutte
le bombe abbandonate nascoste dagli
eserciti ritirata e la fetta più grossa
quella del primo conflitto mondiale che
i malfunzionamenti non erano 10 per 7 al
10 per cento ma bensì al 50 per cento
perché questi questa stima questi numeri
perchè ancora oggi a distanza di cento
anni la gente continua a ferirsi a
morire dati informali parlano di 10
incidenti all'anno causati da queste
bombe inesplose
quindi questo dato ci deve far
riflettere
ma come è fatta una bomba una bomba non
è altro che un contenitore dove
all'interno c'è una sostanza chimica che
si chiama esplosivo ma questa sostanza
da sola non riesce a fare boom
ha bisogno di un qualcosa che gli arriva
dall'esterno quel qualcosa che gli
arriva dall'esterno si concretizza su
questi contenitori di metallo con dei
pulsanti che voi chiamerete interruttore
pulsante che noi tecnicamente chiamiamo
spoletta per le bombe d'aereo per i
razzi per i missili oppure congegno
dell'accensione per una bomba a mano
oppure piatto di pressione o bottone di
pressione per una mina
ma la sostanza non cambia cosa succede
quando noi andiamo ad agire
sull'interruttore la sostanza inizia a
decomporsi il the con borse dalla
sostanza fa sprigionare energia libera
energia sotto forma di pressione e sotto
forma di calore
questa espressione e questo calore
serviranno per spaccare questi
contenitori e proiettare schegge a
distanza a 360 gradi a distanze che
vanno a seconda di quanto è grande il
contenitore quindi avremo bombe grande
come quella che avete visto nella slide
bomba d'aereo avremo delle bombe di
media grandezza come le granate
d'artiglieria una bomba da mortaio e
avremo delle bombe più piccole si ha un
volante di 70 80 grammi di esplosivo che
sono le più pericolose quindi non vi
dovete fare ingannare dalla grandezza
perché molte volte la grandezza già è
sinonimo di pericolosità perché uno vede
qualcosa di grande una bomba grandissima
paura si allontana quelle piccole molte
volte non si vedono e quindi sono le più
pericolose
chi ha la competenza per risolvere
questa problematica la competenza è
affidata all'esercito italiano già dal
dalla fine del secondo conflitto
mondiale è iniziata quest opera di
recupero di queste bombe inesplose e da
oggi ad oggi ne sono state recuperate
tantissime giusto per darvi un'idea il
2016 solo nel centro nord sono stati
effettuati 1260 interventi
ciò significa una media di tre o quattro
interventi al giorno un intervento e non
è riferito una bomba un intervento può
essere riferito pure a 20 30 ordigni
giusto per darvi un'idea questi 1260
interventi è stato l'equivalente di
6.000 ordigni raccolto solo nell'anno
che cosa significa questa parola
bonifica bonifica bonifica non significa
altro non sono altro che quelle
operazioni che dobbiamo mettere in atto
dal momento che viene rinvenuta la bomba
tipo nella slide che vedete dietro le
mie spalle vedete una struttura una
specie di cosa mastodontica un qualcosa
di gigantesco qualcosa di gigantesco in
qualcosa per per far sì che la bomba è
esplosa accidentalmente quando andremo a
metterci le mani per togliere la parte
sensibile che è la spoletta che voi
chiamate interruttore pulsante come lo
volete chiamare è un momento più
delicato è il momento che bisogna stare
attendere può succedere qualcosa
ovviamente quando mettiamo in atto tutte
queste procedure creiamo dei disagi e vi
chiedo scusa a nome di tutti gli
artificieri d'italia quali sono questi
disagi sono evacuazione di quartieri
interi chiusure di strade divieto di
sorvolo chi più ne ha più ne metta
il problema che noi dobbiamo garantire
la sicurezza
la sicurezza si garantisce solo in quel
momento in quel modo
quindi sono delle vere e proprie
esercitazioni di guerra
ora passiamo al racconto del
protagonista della mia storia
chi è l'artificiere l'uomo delle bombe
non è altro che un uomo un soldato
l'uomo delle bombe l'artificiere come lo
volete chiamare l'obiettivo che si
prefigge qual è l'obiettivo che si
prefigge rendere il mondo in cui viviamo
più sicuro come uomo perché essendo uomo
e un padre di famiglia spera di lasciare
il meglio ai suoi figli come soldato
perché all obbligo verso le istituzioni
e come l'uomo delle bombe artificiere
perché è stato addestrato è formato per
quel tipo di problema
qual è la sfida la sfida giornaliera del
del nostro protagonista sono le bombe
inesplose
se sfida lo possiamo chiamare perché
nelle sfide c'è chi vince e chi perde il
protagonista della mia storia è
costretto a vincere sempre ovviamente
l'avversario l'avversario è il tempo che
è trascorso tantissimo
l'incognita l'imprevista la sorpresa la
posta in gioco la posta in gioco è la
responsabilità
e quando si parla di responsabilità si
parla di un uomo e come tutti gli uomini
vivi sentimenti diversi dal momento che
approccio sulla bomba inesplosa al
momento che deve distruggere la bomba
inesplosa
all'inizio sono sentimenti di paura
paura che possa succedere qualcosa paura
che li possa succedere qualcosa
paura che qualcosa possa andare storto
alla fine sono i sentimenti di stati
d'animo diversi quale la gioia
soddisfazione e andato tutto liscio
quindi si torna a casa
ma da chi ha aiutato il il nostro
protagonista per svolgere al meglio il
suo lavoro sicuramente dallo studio
corsi di formazione sicuramente aiutato
oltre allo studio dall'esperienza che si
matura negli anni e non per ultimo è
aiutato dalla tecnologia qui abbiamo un
esempio della nostra tecnologia abbiamo
il nostro amico teddy è di saluto agli
ospiti dove vuole salutare
bene ritorniamo a noi alla fine il
protagonista della mia storia fa una
riflessione e dice un tempo erano quelli
meno fortunati che andavano a cercare le
bombe perché c'era fame miseria povertà
quindi lo si faceva per lavoro
nonostante conoscessero il rischio
perché comunque avevano vissuto la
guerra ma ora in questo momento per un
domani migliore
serve che cosa serve più
sensibilizzazione serve più informazione
per minimizzare il rischio di queste
esplosioni accidentali e comunque
l'esercito c'è e ci sarà sempre e io
spero che oggi in questo teatro davanti
a me ci siano 700 non 700 spettatori ma
se facendo ambasciatori che devono
andare in giro e raccontare per evitare
che succedono questi incidenti grazie
buon uomore i giochi
[Applauso]